hi I'm Marc Guggenheim thank you for
watching arrow season 3 we are already
hard at work on planning out the story
arcs or season 4 you want to find out
how team arrow is gonna continue to save
the city now that the arrow is retired
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie I've already
done flash season 2 predictions so now
it's time to do arrow season 4
predictions so here we go careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen anything
from the season yet just a quick note on
the premiere date everyone's asking like
when arrow flash are coming back they're
gonna premiere the same time they did
last year that first week in October
that could move by a week or two but
tentatively just plan on that first week
in October and yes Oliver will crossover
with legends of tomorrow the rest of the
main cast will crossover with flash same
old same old
you know no big changes there so here we
go top 5 predictions number 5 the arrow
costume and the arrow name are done
Stephen Amell has confirmed that he is
no longer calling himself the arrow and
that name is not coming back so when we
see him in the first part of the season
he's just gonna be Oliver Queen that
doesn't mean he's gonna stop trying to
help people he's still gonna be solving
crimes but he'll be doing it as Oliver
Queen
imagine Bruce Wayne fighting crime
without the bat suit just just like that
that doesn't mean he won't get a new
costume sometime during the season I
definitely think that's gonna happen but
the old arrow costume the either he
actually called it the arrow pants like
the leather pants he used to wear those
aren't coming back on to number 4 Oliver
and Felicity will be in Coast City for
the first part of the season and the
flashbacks will also be in Coast City
and everybody wants to see a bunch of
Green Lantern stuff
Oliver learn to fly somewhere I'm
guessing it was in ko City via Ferris
air even in the flashbacks you know no
promises on Hal Jordan in present-day we
know the test pilot code unquote got
lost Carol Ferris and the people in and
around Ferris air are totally doable
though anybody from the Green Lantern
mythology that is not part of the
Lantern Corps or is not like another
superhero most of the new heroes that
we're gonna see are gonna come via
legends of tomorrow like that's where
most of that energy is gonna go then
being in Coast City is a little bit like
longbow hunters when Oliver Queen went
to Seattle that doesn't mean they're
doing longbow hunters but expect to see
a lot of Easter eggs like in the longbow
hunters storyline he lives in
Seattle with Black Canary she owned a
flower shop called Sherwood florist they
lived above it
expect to see Easter eggs for that kind
of stuff wants number three different
groups of characters for the first part
of the season will have different
storylines that will converge you know
around the midseason finale so what you
see is you have like Oliver and Felicity
in Coast City
they'll have their own mini arc the
first part of the season then you have
team arrow like the new team arrow back
in Starling they'll have their own
little small story line for the perch
part of the season and then an end up
our back you'll have Merlyn Nyssa and
the League with their own small
storyline that'll give them the ability
to bounce all over the world
it'll make arrow much more of an
international show it's just a really
easy way for the show to keep things
fresh in terms of you know fresh places
fresh faces the idea though is is that
all those different storylines will
start to converge towards the mid-season
finale most notably due to the
appearance of The Big Bad each year
during the mid-season finale is like
when the Big Bad is revealed we found
out about Slade during season two in
episode 9 ratio will killed Oliver in
the middle of the season so there'll be
like a big WTF big bad villain moment in
the mid-season finale you can kind of
see how how the different heroes will
have their different problems and all of
a sudden they'll realize that everything
is connected and it has something to do
with hive in the Big Bad which leads
nicely into number two the main villain
will be damian darhk-- he will be part
of hive and he will also be Felicity's
father here's what we know about damian
darhk-- he has the same type of training
Rayshawn ghoul had so he's at least his
equal he has his own version of the
League of Assassins which is what hive
is gonna be in the air overs he probably
has unlimited money and resources
and he has water from the Lazarus Pit so
he will still be just as young as he was
when he first joined the league so it's
probably gonna happen is is they'll cast
someone who's like very young very
good-looking who will look about the
same age as Felicity's so you'll have
this really weird situation whereby she
starts fighting against her father who
looks like he could be her brother there
are a couple really awesome things about
this that I think will help address some
of the issues arrow has with its lesser
characters most notably Felicity one of
the big complaints about the way she was
written this season is that she was
usually crying she was kind of a backup
role she just didn't have a lot to do
she seemed to have a whole lot of agency
in the first part of the season but in
the second half of the season that kind
of
fell down one way to make her step up in
a big way is to make the villain a tech
based villain and make it a family
matter make it her father his meshes
that seems like a really dark Star Wars
turned to take remember Merlyn was
originally supposed to be Oliver's
father that's what the writers wanted to
do but they thought that was to Darth
Vader that's why in the season finale
Merlyn said I've always thought of you
as a son Oliver that was just like a
wink at that but my number one
prediction
Oliver will become the green arrow going
into season five most of his art the
first part of the season is gonna be
figuring out who Oliver Queen is that's
what he said that's why he's going to
Coast City so he can just have some time
away and figure out who Oliver Queen is
because he's been the arrow for so long
it'd be like Bruce Wayne trying to
figure out who Bruce Wayne is because
that's a totally fake mask Batman is the
real persona Bruce Wayne is the mask in
all of us case it's just gonna be Oliver
there'll be no arrow no green arrow no
nothing the first part of the season but
the big crucible that he goes through
this year will help turn him into Green
Arrow you know find the balance the
well-adjusted superhero that could join
the Justice League someday it's helpful
to think about it in a Smallville
context you know think about like how
that show put Clark in the you know the
Superman suit by the final season you
know I think originally the plan was for
arrow to run five seasons so they wanted
to get him to Green Arrow by season five
arrows gonna run way longer than that
like they won't stop at five seasons but
I think because the flash is progressing
the storylines so fast like rolling out
superpowers all this crazy stuff they're
speeding things up on arrow too so
they're getting him - Green Arrow faster
just like they got Laurel - Black Canary
super fast on that same token - Thea
will be the Mia Dearden speedy that
might not have been clear in the finale
when she was like maybe I'll call myself
red arrow and Oliver replied I'm pretty
sure I told everyone to call you speedy
but she will be wearing that red costume
she'll be wearing Roy's costume
basically so here's my big question for
you you know what is your biggest
prediction for arrow season 4 like what
do you want to see them do especially
you know around hive and damian darhk--
I think I said it during my flash video
- but what's gonna happen is is the
first half of the season for arrow in
the flash will build up to the spin-off
show - legends of tomorrow so the plot
of
those shows will explain why the team-up
is necessary but I don't know if vandal
savage is actually gonna appear on arrow
or the flash first and if I haven't
mentioned it before
both Oliver and Barry will go on legends
of tomorrow but probably just them that
it's probably not gonna be like the
entire main cast of air on the flash
going on the spin-off show and everyone
wants to know if Laurel is gonna find
out that Sara's still alive I think that
she will they'll address that somehow
but maybe not till the second half of
the season the version of white canary
that Sara's playing is a big departure
from the comic book so I'll do a white
canary video at some point real soon so
be sure to subscribe to get that if
there's any other arrow specific videos
like anything from the League of
Assassins or Rachel ghoul or damian
darhk-- or hive or anything like that
just leave your requests also be doing a
bunch of other DC TV videos like
Supergirl legends of tomorrow all that
kind of stuff this summer there's so
much that we have to talk about there's
gonna be so much awesome TV this fall so
while you guys wait for all that stuff
you can click here for my flash season 2
predictions there's also a promo for
season 2 at the beginning of that video
and you can click here to learn about
the top 5 craziest Scarlet Witch and
Vision storylines from the comics just
because they're gonna be part of Captain
America Civil War thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow